[Music]
Guardians
One Last Ride
yeah that cool dude it is so cool to get
to sit across from you I just saw this
last night in IMAX volume 3 blew my mind
to be honest it was such an emotional
roller coaster it's just an honor to get
to like sit here and pick your brain
thank you so much thanks yeah well I'm
excited I'm excited for people to see it
in IMAX it's really like just the
absolute greatest way you can see a
movie this movie is especially important
to us because we shot the entire movie
in IMAX and you can't see it like that
in any other theater in the world so
you're gonna see stuff in Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 and IMAX that you just
can't see anywhere else so you'll
probably never see it and it probably
will never be on TV like that it's only
an IMAX and so I think that uh that that
makes it something really special that
makes this movie really special you just
answered like my first three questions
and that's amazing because I that is one
thing that I've come to realize and and
I've learned more about what IMAX
presents and one I know I'd love to dig
a little bit deeper into that yeah
um what kind of went into your decision
to shoot the entire film in one I know
it's it's something that hasn't been
done very often and I think it was so
awesome to see with this film well I
mean I think that first of all I love
seeing movie in IMAX theater and so I'm
always thinking you know if that's the
best way you can see a movie what's the
best way I can shoot it for those
theaters IMAX has been great to me over
the years
um you know more people have seen you
know movies and IMAX theaters probably
than any other theaters Guardians of the
Galaxy movies so to be able to make it
what could possibly be the best format
uh for IMAX that was my thinking behind
it it was to just really service IMAX so
that people can experience a movie the
biggest way possible I can tell you the
feeling is mutual from our side we are
such big fans of you uh so thank you
um I want to dig a little bit into the
sound of the movie right like you're a
musician I think you know the power of
Sound and Music and how it really can
like amplify and experience in a film in
the right moments so I'm just curious is
there a moment
um that you think in IMAX theater is the
sound was something that you really
wanted to fine-tune in a way that
audiences would be blown away well I
worked really hard there's a scene in
the movie that is starts off to
um space hogs in the meantime and it's
the whole gang jumping out into outer
space and they're different colored
spacesuits and they're traveling towards
a satellite called the orgoscope which
is this giant satellite composed of
biological Manner and it's a really
beautiful colors colorful scene with a
wonderful song and then we move out of
that song and we move into the Silence
of outer space with these guys talking
on their headsets and it's almost
totally quiet you know and then we get
into the noises again and I think that
little sequence there to be able to see
that in IMAX because of the bigness of
outer space and the bigness of the song
and then getting as quiet as we possibly
can where every little tiny you know
squeak of you know we did all the
squeaks of the the spacesuits as they
turn and talk to each other the intimacy
between Gamora and quill like that stuff
is going to be just so exciting and IMAX
have you seen this like with like an
audience like just randomly like a bunch
of random people because that scene yeah
I think was one of the loudest like
funny reactions of anything I've seen
recently yeah yeah yeah Guardians France
it was just so good yeah yeah that gets
a big laugh I think there's a couple of
in terms of a sustained scene laughing
that stuff this Nathan Fillion stuff is
so great these little guy gets laughing
every that guy came in he had like three
line in the script he comes in I'm
throwing in more lines and more lines
and more lines than normally you end up
cutting all that stuff you just go back
to what the script was I kept every
single line I threw Nathan Fillion on
set and he just goes on being an idiot
for a long time that's amazing oh my God
I'm kicking out just hearing these
stories to be honest with you I want to
know um I'm going to switch to some more
personal James Gunn stuff sure I would
love to know if you could experience any
movie for the first time again in IMAX
what would it be and why you know the
first thing that pops into my mind is
seeing a Sergio Leone film in IMAX
seeing Once Upon a Time in the West in
IMAX how cool would that be I mean those
big visas that just that that wonderful
ennio morricone you know soundtrack
that's just the greatest soundtrack ever
written boy that would be amazing let's
do that we should really sit in the IMAX
I'm in just come over I'll just like
take the day off just grab popcorn we'll
just do it I'm in like honestly please
um I want to ask you also you know the
soundtracks of not only just this film
but the entire franchise are are
legendary if you could put any song that
you could put in there that you haven't
already thrown in there what would it be
and why
well I got a couple answers to that
first of all I've been trying to work
um Nick Lowe's cruel to be kind into
every Guardians movie and it's never fit
but it seems like such a great Guardian
song but it's never been the right song
and then I'll be honest there's a song
called Uh Russian Roulette by Lords of
the new church it's I every song that
I've ever tried to get for all three
movies I've gotten except for Russian
Roulette by Lords of the new church
that's the one that got away
um I would say I think after watching
your movies there's a solid week where I
just go by and everything I listen to
I'm like this could be in James yeah
that's my life Welcome to my life that's
what I feel like every minute of the day
when I'm
we'll say but amazing thank you so much
it's so awesome I can't wait for people
to see this it's honestly legendary and
it's just not go see an IMX